I just want to know why why Virgil
overdate it if you have to if you have
to just
everything about him is better every
single possible metric of being a human
a virtual Van Dyke is better than John's
hay he's faster stronger he's more
skillful on the ball he's got he's just
got an order about him he's gorgeous
apparently apparently he smells great as
well I come from Troy do you need not
from me by the way
[Music]
right bro to a very important debate
Lewis as the home team who are you going
to be representing and what era are you
going to be debating today I'm going to
be going for Chelsea or 405 Jose
mourinho's side
um 95 Point winning team and the team
the least goals conceded in premier
league history okay all right I'm Paul
who are we going to represent him uh a
better team uh Jurgen klops 1920 title
winning team the one that ended the 38
weeks and finished that season is the
reigning English European and world
champions I got facts you've got facts
now we're going to start with a big
position already we're going front three
we're going right wing a very important
position for both teams Lewis we're
going to start with you as the home team
for this match who's your right winger
uh for me I'm going to go for iron Robin
didn't see a lot of him throughout the
season because of injuries as always but
when he played he was absolutely
electric we call I call him the Eden
Hazard before we had Eden Hazard managed
to still rack up a player of the month
and end up in the Premier League team of
the season even with the limited game
time time they had on ability alone for
me I think you can have a debate over
Robin versus Salah
nope
it's Muhammad I mean the guy was an
absolute gold machine and an assist
machine he is arguably the best player
that's going to go into this team that
is no I just don't see how we can have a
debate in fact there's one of several
positions where I feel there is
literally no debate to be had but Robin
was also viewed as one of the best
swingers in the league That season too
yeah I Winger but yeah and he was fine
and I'm not saying I thought was
absolutely fine but there's a Temptation
with him to think about what came after
in his career and people think about you
know Bundesliga Robin and people think
about all the longevity of his career
now he tormented defenses for years and
years and years and years and years that
was not this Robin this was just a young
kid starting to make his way at the time
I never know Robin at that time was
unbelievable even the limits of time he
did but he was he wasn't even his best
season for Chelsea and that's that's the
point about this and this is I mean
granted not even Mohamed salah's best
season for Liverpool but still miles
better than the what Robin was able to
produce That season it's very I like
wrong I think he's a good player not
that Robin novice is that seller
I don't know for me I I could maybe
concede the left side a little bit more
but for me I have to go fight for Robin
on the right right
so
okay well we'll come to another due
course so you've got it's a hill you're
gonna die on yeah it's an iron Robin who
played like what if we're talking on the
ability in longevity through the season
I think Salah does give we're talking
about the ability of both planets and
assist return
the goal return you can have an assist
return
yeah I kind of get but ability
he was fitter for the entirety of the
Season he scored more goals and he made
more goals
but
I'm not winning this one
I'm gonna be honest with you he he's
kind of got the facts and I think
realistically I don't think that I can
say that I'm Robin is better than Mo
Salah who arguably one of the best
forwards in premier league history not
my favorite but he's up there and for
the sake of this debate Paul
I'm awarding that one to you mate
wonderful stuff easy picking
[Applause]
this we kind of knew it was going to go
that way let's mix it up a little bit
and let's go for go for Striker
Paul who would who are you saying are we
say Striker sort of direct down the
middle it has to be Rebecca for me you
know yeah I understand this is very much
I think I think this is one of the
really interesting debates here
um because I think I think everyone
knows who Lewis is going to go for I
think there's an obvious shelter but
Rebecca for me enough for me in terms of
knitting it all together he's one of
those players who I think in years to
come people will look back on him in
like the same vein as people look at
Dennis Beckham and people look at these
like genius footballers that we were
lucky enough to upgrades the league it's
a strong word do is a strong one a
genuine Genius of a footballer and I've
seen a few uh and I'm filled over the
years and and he definitely ranks up
there
um I understand the obvious criticisms
of him didn't score enough goals for a
number nine but I mean look modern
football how many how many great goal
scorer and number nines are that and to
be honest I'm not sure what Lewis is
going to present is someone who was not
either be honest completely fair but I
think that's I think it's a similar
argument with femino and Drogba where
it's two players that were really good
on the ball they had the technique
um I say Drogba was more of a bully in
terms of the fact that he could
absolutely destroy Defenders but they
used to tear up against Liverpool every
single time he played they're even going
back to Marseille he said playing
against drogma he's still he still was a
brilliant player in terms of his link up
play in terms of his Hold Up play he's
still turned up in big games for us like
we'll use both legs against Bayern
Munich in the quarterfinals as an
example of that obviously like his best
was still yet to come but as a player he
was still instrumental in US winning the
league and dominate through the season
yeah I I think this for me like kind of
looking at where the positions are it is
one of the most difficult because I do
like Bobby firmino as a footballer you
have put very good arguments I'm gonna
give it to Chelsea that I'm giving it to
drug but if I have the juice if I have
to choose when it comes to the link up
play and what he provides I know firmino
does give that but I just I I disagree
so arguably another very important
position the left wing spot Lewis it's
your turn to go first again who are we
having at left wing for Chelsea I know
I'm not winning this one and it's fine
but we're not going to use it to
disrespect Damian you want to try and
make the case for Robin again over on
this side no no if anything I think
money was probably better for you guys
in that season overseller so it's an
even harder debate to make but again
we're not going to disrespect Damian
Duff unbelievable Winger in his time
again one of the best in the league and
was pivotal for us you know 405 as well
but I know I'm not winning this one so
it's okay yeah we said it already so the
Omani
um absolutely Unstoppable for Liverpool
That season we had a little bit of a
saying going around Liverpool fans that
nobody wanted to win the league more
than sadio Mane I think there's
I think there's four maybe five
absolutely nailed on debateless
positions for Liverpool players and this
is this this is the second of them after
Salah for me yeah I mean if I'm honest
with you I've pretty much had the red
cap for this one yeah
no matter what was said that was gonna
happen can we just have a little a
little weird though for the for the lack
of idea Johnson reference in this one
because in tears of goals and goals
created would you put it he doesn't care
I would consider a good Johnson to be a
striker I honestly said he's better than
his output was better than drugs was not
Seasons really no the output probably
was but I think drug was still played
more games and I think overall was still
a little bit better but we do deserve to
give good Johnson to char as well and I
think that's a fair point and that puts
us nicely into the next debate and I'm
sure this is gonna get very very very uh
interesting we have got the Midfield
three now it is your turn to go first
portal
um I kind of guess we're just gonna go
for the best three midfielders so who do
you want to start with in kind of
whichever a central Midfield role let's
say that yeah
um the big question in this is that
where do we put on land paths so where's
where's the Lampard position which one
are we pray again because as much as I
would love to and there's a little past
like can I make a strong case against
them there's no Liverpool midfielder
there that comes close to touching and
and it would undo every argument I've
made previously and say as well but
ridiculous Chelsea top goal scorer you
know assists go Lord as well
if for me I think there's definitely one
spot off for grabs because Chelsea
Chelsea's weak link there is Thiago
right
um a man's so forgettable that I
actually went right in an ultimate
before I put an H in his name and I had
to realize
at the start and thiago's mentioned I
was like oh hang on a minute nobody
second yeah nobody remembers the
existence so I tell you what we will do
and I think this is a shout is so we can
have a proper
fight should we say about the other two
I'll just do that and we'll put Frank
Lampard
I don't know if the DM is I think we can
just have say three midfielders but if
you want if we want to do it that way we
can do centimeter down but I think
there's no point wasting time with lamp
but we know he's going to be in there no
I won't switch these I'd ask Jordan
Anderson right at the Midfield three if
I was being picky over to be honest
football raters Player of the Year in
1920 as an absolutely Stellar season for
us brilliant human being brilliant
footballer a bit unfashionable as a
footballer but again it's peers and the
football writers recognized how good a
player he was that season I think if you
compare I'm putting people into Thiago
and I there's no contest there respect
to Thiago uh great defensively minor
midfielder but I understand it as well
Henderson has to go and that was his
standout season for Liverpool it's not
really fair to debate it so yeah I could
concede that one easily too
you know what you two are not fighting
too hard at the moment I think the
fights come the further backwards yeah I
know trust me these are not counters
these are mines
I'm aware of what's covered so I believe
even though we've conceded I do agree
with you Henderson did have an
absolutely fantastic season it Pete
Jordan Henderson I can't argue with that
any ghost thank you very much so I mean
I guess we're going to call this the DM
position because I know you guys are
sure there is another name for it isn't
there and this is where I feel I might
be in a spot to bother because what is
the other name
which is why I feel like this argument
already speaks for itself but Claude
mcaleili literally revolutionized that
position and we can talk about lampard's
importance in the Midfield but we also
need to talk about Claude mcileney's
importance as well being able to screen
the backlight and being able to push the
ball forward and start attacks and the
reason why it was so good going forward
as well is because we could rely on
Machi lady every single time there was a
counter attack so for me it has to be
machalei no debate I will make the case
for fabinho because I think again this
is this is the struggle with any of
these kind of things when this there's
just enough of a gap between these two
teams
the the style of football and how
football has moved on I'm not sure
Mahalia is anywhere near as good in the
modern premier league as he was as
effective there I think fabino is the
Liverpool call them like the lighthouse
in their team is the thing around
everything revolves in that side
but
look again I will leave this to you
because I will I will defend for being
new to the end degree I think he's
actually sensation I really he's the
best DM in the Premier League but
it's very hard and in fact it's
basically impossible to argue against a
guy who defined an entire position
Nostalgia is a huge powerful Factor
um and I can see how that's gonna hamper
my case ever so slightly it's a tough
one for me because I was very sort of
strong on macaroni but you did put up
some fantastic points about fabinho but
just because the fact they defined the
role I've got to give this one to uh
Lewis I've got to give it to Macaroni
mate I was tougher than it then maybe it
should have been you did put up some
good points
um but that's what we're gonna go for
now I'm guessing things are going to
start to get a little bit interesting
because
we're gonna talk center backs now Lewis
you are the home team so once again I'm
going to let you go first this one we're
going to kind of do it as a pairing I'm
going to let you sort of put up a
discussion for two center backs who are
we going for I'm sure I can guess one of
them see it is the thing I completely
understand the ability and how good Van
Dyke was in 1920. I really do not want
to sugarcoat that because then it's just
going to come across as delusional Van
Dyke was unbelievable through that
season John Terry and Carvalho however
conceded the least goals in premier
league history and nobody has even come
close to that ever since so I think John
Terry already walks into it even though
you could make an argument that car
value was probably better than him in
that season anyway
so personally I want to be brave and I
want to go for both spots I won't call
Value and treaty how do you respond for
wow I am I think he vegemons like is
a generationally talented footballer I
think car value was just another really
good sense of that for the time when you
ask people to list the best Premier
League centers of all time his name
doesn't come in the top file unless
you're the Chelsea fan what I want to
know so this is the thing I will know if
I'm going to be dead honest here I think
we know that for me it has to be vbdjt I
can't put I'm sorry as much as you want
to say about cover I'm just going to
make the debate no of course and I kept
it but I'm sorry I cannot put Ricardo
Cavalier no matter how good you say it
was in that season the head of Virgin
Van Dyke I can't do that if we were to
put what I kind of want to know is who
we're going for if we've got to say put
one of the two vvd or John turn if it
could only be one of them I just want to
know why why Virgil overdate it if you
have to if you have to it's just
everything about him is better every
single possible metric of being a human
about virtual Van Dyke is better than
John's hay it's faster stronger he's
more skillful on the ball he's got he's
just got an order about him he's
gorgeous apparently apparently smells
great as well I come from Troy do you
need not from me by the way
um it's just he is like if you were
gonna if you're gonna create a human
being
that would be it would be in the
silhouette of Virgil Van Dyke not John's
I as a player I believe John Terry was
unbelievable in that season and it was
like not going to say his breakout
season but the first season where you
actually saw him as one of the best in
the world but I do believe John Terry's
see uh better Seasons came later on in
his career I do believe that's one of
but I don't believe that's completely
his best one and personally you could
make much more of an argument for
Ricardo Carvalho it was much more the
finished product at the time
um probably a bit of a better ball
playing Center back at the time as well
I could potentially argue go Van Dyke
and car value I really want to do it I
I'm not against that as an idea and I
think I think car value was and again
it's not necessarily what I arguing but
I think Carvalho has more of the skill
set that would make him a modern Premier
League sent it off as well so I've got
car value so you won't cover that I'd go
car value I really would I think he's
very very underrated personally I mean I
don't know what to do I've got
it right
I've got to give one to you and I've got
to give one to you now I
the thing is is I kind of it's a bit of
a weird one here you actually want
Carvalho in there opposed to John Terry
I just don't know if we did 14 15 09 or
10 Chelsea John Terry goes in for I just
I don't think I think John Terry the
reason why people talk about him so much
in that season is because you could see
the potential that he was starting to
realize at that time but he didn't get
to that point yet he wasn't there yet
okay if Chelsea fans I'm giving this to
Carvalho I can't believe I've just said
those words that the center-back
partnership for this is Van Dyke and
Carvalho but I'm listening to reason
people who know football and Lewis is a
man he's a Chelsea fan and he's he took
a lot of sense today so I'm gonna step
back and I'm gonna accept
your decision on that this one's for you
Wayne Bridge
I have I have accepted a decision on
that
um
for me
the most interesting debate actually in
the whole team it's the goalkeeper
position
kind of feel like I said this before it
to me it's almost like um you gotta
choose your nan it doesn't really matter
which one you go for they're both great
check in Alison Lewis I'll let you have
the first go on this one why Peter check
um per check first season at Chelsea
also is breakout season at Chelsea again
we can see that the least goals of the
Premier League That season and it wasn't
just because of the defense and machalee
Peter check played a major part of it is
reaction time
um his diving saves our distribution I'm
not really sure about compared to Alison
I could concede that argument but even
in terms of competition like people
don't take it into account the guy came
in within five games bench Carlo
kudachin who was one of the best
goalkeepers in the league at that time
and after a month or two it wasn't even
a debate Chelsea fans were questioning
at the time I view petitech is the best
goalkeeper of all time let alone in that
season so for me it has to be pair check
nothing's brilliant I think he's
absolutely brilliant and he was a
Transformers a player for Chelsea
exactly the way that Allison was for
Liverpool I've never seen a goalkeeper
as good in one-on-one situations I've
never seen a goalkeeper with the the
range of passing and distribution that
Allison's got it is ridiculous Alison is
just an absolute monstering goal and
it's not just like distribution with his
feet is thrown and all that stuff is
Excellence I think if you're holding
them up I think there is there is
nothing between them in terms of how
they delivered on that season in real
terms and it's reflected in all the
awards doing and all the teams of the
year the voted into so what it comes
down to for me is do you want your
goalkeeper to be able to pass the ball
or not and if you want a goalkeeper who
can move the ball and he can play as
almost like as an 11th player on the
pitch for you as well as make all the
saves and do all those kind of things
then that's that's what Allison Allison
had more to his game than petitech if
we're going off what they did in the
season and and I I'm gonna have to kind
of say with that
I just think the fact that Czech managed
to get kuduchini out of a team also
ridiculously Talent goalkeeper it's
close and I Alison is a fantastic
fantastic goalkeeper she likes vanilla
ice cream I I do indeed yeah I do indeed
I gotta do it okay I've got to do it and
I know I'm gonna get stick for it and
I'll take the stick and if I went for
Alison I'd get stick for not choosing
check I just want to make that clear I
like I like Alison at work we've got the
left back and right back left
um port side you want to start you can
you can choose whatever you like left
back right it doesn't matter in any way
shape or form because I've got both of
these here
um
that's why I needed the goalkeeper
let's go in let's go Andy Robertson to
to stars at left back you're lucky here
really that you didn't have Ashley Cole
because this is the big thing I had a
little wobble here when I was trying to
like prepare for this because in my head
Ashley Cole was in this team and I went
so far as to like kind of draw it out
and I was like oh my word was he playing
three at the back because there's coal
how did they fit that in with gas was
Galaxy but the third cents a half no no
that was Joe Cole which is hilarious
we've not even mentioned him today
um but the fact is it this should be a
much closer to the base if it was Ashley
Cole and I do and I think I still think
Andy Robertson will come out on top by
the way but I yeah I
I what I was phenomenal but again what
it's an either thing and I'll tell you
okay I'll tell you what I will give you
if we're going on the season I would
give it to Robertson because I think in
that year he was the best left back in
the world so I'll give you that however
ability wise I think best Premier League
left back ever is Ashley Cole and we've
also take the longevity that's a
question for when the touch of things at
Chelsea yeah
I would say again big up William Gallas
I always for a center-back he fit into
the left back roll seamlessly he was a
brilliant defensively minded uh left
back for us still popped in with some
goals here and there but
I think we pretty much
actually
I think would have been and I I
genuinely think if we if we're going off
the eras I would have probably had to
give it to Robertson because I did feel
at the time once again I don't know
Liverpool
not I
Peak I think
Lewis it's gonna be a tough one for you
here at right now as well I I don't want
Paolo Ferreira to fall under the radar
the way people always do because he was
so underrated he was an unbelievable 1v1
Defender and I don't think anyone ever
gives him the credit that he deserves
but if I'm really gonna try and go into
an argument with 1923 which like you
said had the output was still good
defensively even if he wasn't on
ferreira's level and was just
overworldly when it comes to being able
to attack from that position
it's a long debate it is a very long
debate I I want to push for Paulo
Ferreira as much as possible I don't
think I'm winning that one hey I'll let
you put your case up because
unbelievable on the right hand side and
yeah you did get pushed out of his spot
uh very early into his Chelsea Career
which is annoying it's very annoying but
yeah it's just you can have that it's
Ferrero Glenn Johnson isn't it um and
look and realize it's not it's Trent or
Trends or Trends Alexander Arnold or
Trenton or anything any mixture without
its strength the best right back I think
by the time he finishes his career he
might well be known as the best right
buff to play the game you know he's 24
years old this season if he never
improves even fractionally above what he
is the cutting balance of assist this
guy gets on on a seasonally basis is
absurd for what he's doing we talk about
the Makaveli roll that will be called
the Trent role by the time he's retired
if it's not already he's totally
redefined what a right back to the point
now where everyone wants one everyone
wants to write back who can do more no
one says right backs have got to defend
any more idiots well but can't defend
right I've raped Trent very very
absolutely that's not okay okay and I'll
tell you this I I've rent I rate Trent
Alexander on a ridiculously highly
stupidly good footballer ridiculous
Crossing ridiculous passing ability
defensively not good enough we'll go
back to the argument at hand I think we
know that that's going to to tread and I
just think when it comes to England for
example if you want to go more defensive
you've got Walker but he plays in the
center-back and it gives Trent selfie
can give him Christmas off
so here we go Lads that is the team that
we've come up with Lewis thoughts that
you're a little bit unhappy about the
back line I thought I would have been
able to sneak two center-backs in 15
goals can see that also yeah and we only
got one Center back in the back in the
back four but Jose always spoke about
how the spine of the team mad the most
and then you would just fit other
players around itself it's hit we have
the span of the team in the middle I
think it emphasizes it all perfectly I
still can't believe we've got one Center
back in this cool it's cool I get it I
think that's a as good a team as we were
likely to come together on I think if
you put for me you know
for being Johan Allison in that team it
would be unstoppable well great chat
guys thank you very much for killing
Cheers Cheers
[Music]